[Music]
hi I'm will and this is Tabata Tabata is
an high-intensity interval training
protocol that our professor in Japan
came up with in 1996 he created this 20
seconds of work 10 seconds of rest over
8 rounds so I can incorporate anything
across the board you can do with push at
the bottom burpees Tabata situps what
CrossFit is done is they take in the
Tabata a timing protocol and taking it
into their bag of tricks Oh what do we
have we have 4 minutes what can we do
where can we increase this athletes
aerobic activity and actually it will
increase your anaerobic activity as well
because we'll throw in weighted
activities this is your at-home Tabata
workout so we're here with another
Tabata style this is an endurance style
workout so what are we doing with these
so the first move we have is the jump
rope we're going to attempt to do double
unders which is passing the rope under
your feet twice on one hop if that's not
in our wheelhouse today we will just
supplement normal skipping rope ok we do
that for 20 seconds the next part is the
Burpee lateral jump you're gonna perform
a full Burpee so chest to the ground
Chuck Burpee jump ok
20 seconds 20 a second to that 10
seconds rest back to here 3 2 1 go
I might stick the singles just to keep
my heart rate up right now yes because
you are advanced you can do the doubles
that'll warm seconds of rest okay here
we go in three two one and go
Burpee lateral good the goal here is to
not whoa stop so even if you have to go
slow you never want to stop your pace
good
five seconds take it one more three two
one ten seconds to rest
deep breath you go three two one go
[Applause]
three two one
take a rest two one hit the deck over
good
that's her keep it up and rest good Wow
okay so to recap your tabata endurance
exercise start off with 20 seconds of
rope jumps 10 seconds rest jump into 20
seconds of the Burpee lateral jumps 10
seconds to rest repeat that four times
that's your endurance Tabata workout I
like it great work man I'm gonna work on
my rope jumps make sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any other fighting
weight episodes
[Music]